[Music]
hey rob this is stephanie abes from
dallas texas
i have a couple of questions
one is the oroville
i wanted to know about how the filming
was that how that was on the
pilot
and
um if you're
in into
sci-fi
and then the other thing is since i'm
from texas we are watching the 9-1-1
lone star show
and we do
like it i was wondering where you filmed
the winter scenes
from the beginning of the season
thank you love you bye
oh thank you for calling um
so
uh the orville um i'm a big seth
macfarlane uh friend fan um know him
i've done some stuff uh on family guy
over the years he asked me to play uh
derulio the blue alien
and he called me and
said i'll send you the script
and in the very first scene he is in bed
with a girl as you know and he
ejaculates out of his forehead
i was in after that
i i didn't read anything else i didn't
read the rest of the script i said me
playing a blue alien ejaculating out of
my forehead i'm in
and
it's it's it's funny but it also people
always say how do you
keep yourself relevant how do you keep a
career going
after so many years when other people
don't that that's a very good example of
how and why
because there are plenty of people like
what i'm an alien and what well little
people that's great yeah
and i'm just like makes me laugh i'm in
um
i love sci-fi love it i'm bummed that i
haven't done anything in sci-fi truly i
would love it
i would love to do you know aliens you
know and a star wars thing look i was on
the set of star wars i write about it in
my my first book um stories i only tell
my friends
um i went to the the what was the
original ilm industrial light magic and
and and watched them film
the uh
uh death star trench
uh fighter pilot sequence and um saw
r2d2 and the bantha all in the same and
the death star it had not come out
i had my aunt my aunt and uncle were
working as rotoscopers they used to call
them
um and i remember going to my seventh
grade class the next day and going
there's a movie coming out soon
that is going to be so good called star
wars
i wish i would have invested in it yeah
so maybe maybe um
my overlords at disney who produce
911 lone star and now own all the star
wars stuff we'll hear this
and put me in that world i would love
that and um the last part of your
question thank you for watching um 911
lone star
all of that snow blizzard which i was
super proud of you know we're not a
movie we're a tv show so
you know we have budgets we have to
adhere to we make a lot of them it's
like a factory and i and i take great
pride that it looks like a movie every
week
and that looked amazing
that blizzard stuff looks so real
it was shot in 100 degree weather
in simi valley in california
we had fake snow technology
we used um
a certain type of smoke to make it look
white and foggy
and then they put this special makeup to
put on my beard which looks like ice
icicles on my beard but man it looks
like we're in a blizzard it was real
movie making magic glad you liked it
thanks for calling
you